two alright for the honorable judge
ethan klein
this episode is brought to you by rage
and quip
thank you everybody thank you bailiff
you may be seated
welcome everybody to another session of
the content court i am your honorable
judge
ethan klein this court is now
in session today we are looking
at the conquest of the
aced family this is not our first look
at a family yeah conquest i'm gonna even
say conquest
they have conquered youtube this channel
is extraordinary big
coming almost to 20 million subscribers
and the the breadth of their enterprises
is astounding as someone who hasn't
followed them
barely knew about their existence i'm
shocked by their popularity
and so let's take a look and see what is
the ace family up to
a little background ace family consists
of three original members you've got
katherine and i guess the
the husband is a college basketball star
austin mcbroom was he really a
basketball star college basketball but
yeah
and there are three children ella ally
and steele that's kind of a badass name
steel
[ __ ] yeah i think it's just l
a liar oh l they got the name ace family
by using the first
letters of the original three cast
members austin catherine
l ace ace family has attracted more than
19 million subscribers since launching
their youtube in 2016.
now their once humble vlog is a
full-time cringe
enterprise growing bigger every day
next slide they're being charged today
with statutory douchebaggery
what does statutory actually mean by the
way
like like statutory isn't that underage
well i i think the expression is just
referring to
it's by some sort of criminal statute
it's not you're thinking of statutory
rape
is but that that's just one statutory
yeah
no vin we don't we don't talk to you
baby
diesel you mentioned
statutory rape and finance to me
baby that's the best thing ever
i noticed you were really quiet during
the episode with belle delphine
too thank you for refraining during that
a lot of people come
oh my god criminal snakeishness hmm
and misdemeanor destructive delusions
jesus is okay
going in huh all right opening
statements a b
would you like to begin by saying your
case against the ace family please
thank your honor yes today we'll be
visiting the ace family
a family who on the surface looks like
they are the perfect disney fairy tale
dream
they have everything they have looks
they have seemingly they are happy
but taking a deeper look it seems like
there's more to the story
and part of me feels bad talking about
what looks like such a genuinely happy
family
but another part of me maybe call it my
conscious your honor
says who you kidding me we need to go
after these guys
they're full of [ __ ] and today i present
a case to the court
that i think will prove that they are
not what they seem thank you
i like uh the court definitely
recognizes the who you're kidding
and so certainly taken uh note taken
uh a i n j do you have any uh retorts
[Music]
wait whose hand is that handing you a
microphone and it's like backwards
don't worry about it okay why are we
holding a mic today
i just wanted to try something a little
more loose a little more free flowing
why no i don't know
i'll mix it up all right so what's your
opening statement we're reinforcing
family values
it's
all i'm saying is family values are lit
and cool
and awesome and cool well are you saying
they're f
they have good family values i mean
why are you twitching angry are you
yeah it looks like these shorts
when i think about people you know
talking down on
families family values bonding
it just really grinds my freaking gears
i don't understand what is it because he
has no family
he is a family he's connected to the
internet every robot every toaster is
his
cousin that's very polite
okay i'm not quite sure what your point
was but uh thank you for submitting
whatever that was
all right thank you lawyer baby
okay all right thank you very much
i don't know what that was
all right moving on let's start first
charge statutory douchebaggery
we have a what the [ __ ] is this what is
this picture of
uh that is a his face on a douchebag
all the time right yeah
i never knew what a dish bag was you
insert it and then you squeeze and i
guess it rinses
god bless but does anyone use this
i don't know i mean i'm assuming some
people use douches and anyway here's one
with
i would buy that's pretty cool merch
actually i feel like that's kind of cool
merch
that's true all right the jet ski
situation
in august of 2019 the ace family
uploaded video of austin riding a jet
ski in his swimming pool
spilling excessive water out all down
the hill
there were complaints that the water was
causing mudslides and damaged the
neighbor's property
there's so what i'm going to show you is
the video his video and then i'm going
to show you
the neighbors video kind of the two
perspectives
now this video has 9 million views by
the way august 2019.
you know he's they live in woodland
hills by the way so although
i know they have like this huge
expensive beautiful house but woodland
hills is a working-class neighborhood
they're on top of the hill so it's not
like they're pouring water down on like
super rich people's houses and stuff
these are like very working class people
whoops let's go
oh my god you're disrespectful to our
pool
what you're so disrespectful to our pool
about your neighbors dump them
oh my gosh i can't believe you're
actually doing this
ace family like six months ago austin
said he was gonna get a jet ski in this
pool
and i didn't think he was actually going
to do it hey family this pool is so big
that you could put it
it's not that big right in the pool but
why not
[ __ ] that you only got one life to live
i tell everyone
you only got big but not jet ski big
tell him in the comments that this is
disrespectful yeah it's not the ocean
it's nothing so hey i would never do
anything
so i think that's it the the other video
you can see he's really displacing what
[Music]
okay so anyway this is the view of the
neighbors downhill from him
wow let's go there's another video which
i'll show you afterwards which is way
worse
you see all the water spilling out here
oh
just straight up mudslides oh my god
just tons of mud pouring out into the
neighbor's yard
which i mean my first thought was like
that seems poorly built
stop oh that was my favorite part
stop the neighbor's screaming stop so
this was the first time
okay wow even after he created a
mudslide in the neighborhood
he did it again are you serious watch
this one this one's even crazier
[Music]
watch how much water you displace look
at this
why are you doing that oh my god
look at all this water he displaces dude
stop
so you know
no this is not cool
this guy's like look at all the water
coming out of the pool
it's mentally like five-year-old
well what yeah look at this oh my god
you know when you're in the ocean and
you do this stuff to like splash
water on people he's doing that with
mudslides to his working-class neighbors
so um wow
so there you go the jet ski situation
stop
that's definitely a situation you know
it's a perfect example of just because
you can do something doesn't mean you
should do something
right and also
over a not fully functioning brain
well yeah i think they have like vlog
vlog vlogitis where it's like you have
brain virus of the vlogger where you
just do dumb [ __ ]
it's like what happens to jake paul he's
like i need to make content
now my pool in the backyard's on fire
and i'm burning down the whole
neighborhood and the mayor's tweeting at
me
or the suicide forest i'm trying to get
some attention
it should be a condition the suicide
forest
conditions yeah well like vlogitis yeah
it's like vlogitis
right it is it is of mental condition
it's just not well
researched yet here's one of the
neighbors saying hey can the next
douchebag
be the ace family for running jet ski in
the pool and creating mudslides to
destroy my uncle's property and grapes
they have done it multiple times and we
told the city but they continued to do
it
oh my god oh and then so so she was
she responded this woman by the way who
has
she goes out in response to this guy who
said you destroyed my uncle's yard
she said oh nothing people just hate to
see happy people minding their own
business
living their life and staying in their
own lane so i'm just smiling at them
how do we know this is in response to
that no it wasn't
she tweeted this she just tweeted these
smiley faces
after this person tweeted someone said
what's happening
yeah yeah someone asked what's happening
and she explained i mean
i feel like they have like a legitimate
grievance you should just say sorry and
not do it again
what's with the staying in their own
lane your mod didn't stay in your lane
yeah you literally didn't stay in your
lane
like quite literally
what lane are we talking about and then
someone said if you're mad jealous at
the ace family house what does that say
about you instead of coming up with
reasons why
that you shouldn't have this life come
up with reasons why you should being
sour about their beautiful house is
nowhere to start
and definitely louder he says say it
louder mama
wow what a great community they're
they're brewing there just say
we're sorry we won't [ __ ] put a jet
ski in our pool anymore
you know damn you're just jealous
yeah i am you're just definitely and
yolo are two common defenses that they
give
i mean the jealous defense is quite
versatile i have to say
it's for quite versatile okay moving on
to the next
uh crime here stealing designs from a
smaller
designer our favorite yeah we're very
familiar with this
austin came across some headband
designer he was a fan of and reached out
to see if they wanted to collaborate the
designer goes by the name of urban
trademark seven
the two gentlemen meet up and they
allegedly agreed on doing a collab
shortly after this meeting austin
released his own headbands that looked
like a ripoff of urban trade seven's
design
austin also allegedly copied his mobile
merch store idea
as well so let's look at the evidence
here now here's
on the right is the dms between them
that this guy posted
austin said what's good bro i randomly
popped in your shop today and i got a
couple of headbands i noticed
your username on the tag and wanted to
hit you up to see if you're interested
in collabing let me know
and he was just like yeah for sure let's
meet up yada yada so
here's this guy kind of retelling
retelling we've been getting a lot of
comments lately
asking us what happened what happened
with
the ace family in this truck so
we just wanted to address it and let you
guys hear
firsthand from our mouths what really
happened
my first thought when i saw this video
was like turn the music up bro
you got a vibe turn that music up i
don't want
i don't want to hear what he has to say
just
chill for a minute i think it's funny
when they play the music too loud
you're like what what
oops that's five let's find out that's
hot
comments lately and let you guys hear
firsthand from our mouths
turn it up he reached out from the text
messages that i post
the show just um link up and try to put
something together
we linked up uh first thing when i got
there he's like bro did you bring some
bands bro i want to get some more from
you
i'm like yeah i got some in the car so
then from there
i was like all right well what i could
do is i could make a couple exclusively
for you
and then we could sell them and then you
know when i link back up i'll make them
when i link back up we can negotiate
like the price and a couple days later
i seen on youtube he had on the bench
some bands that looked like fortnite but
him and his daughter
it was mad that it wasn't i just know my
work and i was like
i was like come here look at this i hit
him up i'm like bro what's up with this
people do that man people turn it up it
is really
loud so fast that i'm not the only one
that's been done too i'm pretty hey
hey feeling this beat i can't really
hear what he's saying
another thing with dope is i'm working
you should be shouting
that um we can like basically rewind
time
every band that i make exclusively for
you we pop
up zach why are you playing will smith
sounds bites yeah i feel like it's
vaguely racist
you're playing will smith sound bites i
just want to throw that out there
like what's the relevance
i mean i didn't even
put two and two together though all
right does that guy have a defense
lawyer
zack uh aiem what do you say in the
uh dude would you like to prosecute zach
i'm gonna have to pass on this case
he was he was just vibing i wasn't
trying to be racist i was just about
to do it i'm just kidding i was enjoying
it i just thought i'd call you out it's
fine
yeah i was laughing when i heard will
smith hmm it's rewind time ah
that's right we've been getting a lot of
comments lately just giving you our time
keep it up i don't i don't wanna
yeah i don't wanna disrupt your creative
juices bro please don't
working on a truck that um
we can like basically do pop-ups where
every band that i make exclusively for
you
we pop up we can sell them and then you
know
all right bro let me do it i really suck
at this let me explain better than you
here can you play some super loud music
as i describe what he's trying to say
basically austin came he said yo i like
your headband let's collab
then he disappeared and he put out
headbands similar to his
but then what really pissed him off
turned it
[Music]
and so this guy's whole thing is he
cruises around an ice cream restaurant
[Music]
well here let me show you and you can
decide if you think
but i'm already like so upset by this
because
the ace family i don't know anything
about them but one thing i can tell for
sure already they're
huge and they're rolling in it they got
they got the bags just right they
secured the bags
just wait so um why are you gonna do
that
to someone who's being a creative
independent artist
i agree like be a little generous if
anything
i agree yeah you want to you want to
help you want to help people out who are
trying to make it you know especially
independent artists
so here on the left is their headband by
the way headband merch is pretty niche
so
already it's like but this is their
their their headbands on the right are
very like
print all over colorful uh patterns
right
so these are the two there's no it's not
like a blatant ripoff of any of the
designs it's more like a
conceptual coincidence pretty clear what
happened though
you know i agree and now here so here's
the truck thing
so this is his mobile truck that he
cruises around and sells his headbands
in
and then all of a sudden the guy from
ace family austin
mcbroom yeah i'm gonna [ __ ] sweep his
ass out of this courtroom
mcbroom
and so this is his ice cream truck yeah
that's ridiculous
and so now now he now awesome by the way
gets defensive as usual
and starts trashing on this dude on his
uh instagram live
listen i think there was some other
[ __ ] random ass dude talking about
i [ __ ] copied his ice cream truck who
the [ __ ] is i don't even know what a
[ __ ] he is
i forgot all about him i met with this
dude literally over a year ago
talking about his headbands i liked his
headbands went to the store saw some
headbands hit him up on the collab he
didn't want to collab with me
because he tried to say that the
headbands were expensive
he was bullshitting he was trying to get
over on me so i said you know what bruh
by the way you know that's not true he
definitely wanted to collab with you
it's huge opportunity for him
you know what i mean yeah you know what
i'm gonna have my grandma make me my own
headbands
because everybody sell headbands in the
stores everybody all the stores sell
headbands you ain't the first headband
maker who the [ __ ] you think you are
you're inventor of headbands
idiot so i made my own hairbands he got
mad because i posted it and i had a
little following
he got mad it was wearing my headbands
with l he was like
he he tried to take my idea he
took my the idea where you put the
banner on your head and you cross it and
you tie it and you put it in your head
he stole that from me austin from the
ace family stole
my art and i don't like them
don't like them right so then a year
later
just like fred i'm i'm oh the ace
family's blowing up
i'm itching for that clout pill i need
that clout
ace family blowing up they got over 10
million subs i'm trying to get some
attention
it comes out after we have made an ice
cream truck from sd
raps they literally customize this
random as [ __ ] they came up with it with
their own
he starts by saying i don't even
remember this guy and then he details
every [ __ ]
single thing that happened between them
like you clearly remember it quite
vividly real quick too
the offhanded mention of fred i looked
into that
fred was their original director of
their videos on their channel
uh who they uh stiffed for a bunch of
money and then
he revealed that he they were actually
only paying him 150 bucks
per video what 150 but that's not even
like going
great no and that guy did a whole
exposed thing as well about that's not
even a day rate for like a gaffer
no that's not he had a great for uh for
uh for anybody he agreed to do it for
that
for for credit in their videos and then
they didn't credit him
like they would agree they're so wealthy
too yeah why are you being so
just wait like the the cherry on top is
coming oh
you think these [ __ ] are cheap
just wait i can't believe
the whole thing is just out there
[ __ ] on this poor guy
like for no reason sending he said at
this point he has 10 million followers
so he's sending all that
to this guy and if you look at the
comments everyone's like
cry laughing emoji clapping it's like
yeah
also watch this i don't know what he's
thinking that he's like doing some eddie
murphy a bit or something
yeah he thinks he's a comedian you're
not he thinks he's kevin hart or
something
yeah i need that clown ice cream truck
literally in a day right we
release it he tries to come out and say
we took his idea from getting an ice
cream truck
you know how many ice cream trucks are
out there
what do you mean how many ice cream
trucks right here like are you
you're not selling ice cream yeah he's
not accusing you of inventing an ice
cream truck bro
and did y'all see what his ice cream
truck look like it's half the size
of this cool you're rich you have a big
ice cream truck you definitely didn't
copy him
all right skin truck is bigger half the
size of that [ __ ] so
i'm just hot like i'm a star i might
really start selling the clout pill
that's gonna really help people
like a lot let's go it's gonna save a
lot of lives and keep a lot of people
from getting in trouble so i might
invent the clout pill
so this is this is what he says about
all the people who i quote are haters he
says they're trying to get the clout
pill
yeah it sounds like he's oding on that
clout
well you know if you're if you're
if you're if you are uh have already
named the clout pill i think you may be
having too many conflicts with people
yeah if you're already kind of you know
what i mean
good point though you got to check the
dosage on that yellow right
i need that clout when you take too much
cloud pill you end up in a jet ski on a
jet ski in your pool causing landslides
when you hear your neighbor yelling stop
and you're like
bro you're jealous right you're just on
the clock you're chasing that
clout pill bro stop you're flirting with
me stop
haters
[Laughter]
yeah this shit's great right okay and
now
austin has been accused multiple times
of cheating on his wife
[Music]
now obviously there's no concrete proof
what i can only
show you is the evidence and we can draw
our best assumptions
it's not conclusive and these are not
statements of fact these are
we are just simply reviewing the
evidence okay
in a snapshot video uploaded by alyssa
violet you can see austin in the back of
a car full of other girls while his wife
is at home
pregnant this video was taken after
2018. alyssa violet you know who she is
yeah
okay so you tell me what you would think
if you were if if if this was me and you
saw this and you were at home pregnant
with theodore
look
no well i think what's important is to
see what's going on in that car
yeah he's in the car
[Music]
he's there
he's in the [ __ ] whatever this
is man this ain't a scene for a married
man i'll tell you that
but that's oh my goodness and so all the
fans and stuff are worried about him and
stuff
and oh i'll play the whole video
[Music]
everyone's like yo uh how was coachella
why were you in the car drunk while your
woman's at home taking care of toddlers
this video seems off i'm worried they
had a fight
i saw this snapchat he says he left
coachella because he doesn't drink or
smoke yeah he was obviously shit-faced
in the back of the car
his body was just completely off he
didn't peed in my basement
he just beat in his basement
okay and then his wife yet again
comes to the response someone says i
just realized
i would be torn up if i saw him if i saw
them slip
up because this drama legit stressing me
out she said what drama
my husband and i are happy as [ __ ]
by the way that's kind of a red alert
that statement alone
we're happy as [ __ ] yeah i swear when
people reach any level of success people
just want to bring joy
bring joy down with them
weird-ass people this girl is concerned
for you you're gonna call her weird-ass
people
i actually thought her statement of all
the ones i read was really the nicest of
them all
that's so funny there's like a fan
that's worried for them
i i dude if i
you worried for me you weird ass weirdo
that situation don't bring me down i
don't think that was a good
look for a married man to be in that
situation
while his pregnant wife's at home you
know what i mean
like straight up there are some straight
up weirdos
on the internet pretty objectively bad
situation no i'm not saying he
you know he cheated but the lord knows
it doesn't look good right
yeah i just think it's funny she they
get so defensive
instead of being like you know what he
was in a city
he was just in the car with them it's
all how about like thank you for your
concern
she's like i would be devastated if
anything hap ever happened with you guys
[ __ ] you bitch-ass hater okay
i need that clout
uh here we continue on further
allegations
twitter and instagram account at bella
cgrr
said that austin was cheating on his
wife catherine some said austin slept
with some of her friends and made them
sign an nda
hey girl the odds you'll read this are
slim tonight i want to let you know
because
oh so this is a message she got from
some random apparently
oh is she posting them yes
the girl the other girl posted them hey
girl although you read this slim dinan i
want to let you know because you deserve
to know as a mother
and as a woman last weekend awesome was
with some friends mine in miami he slept
with one of them and made her sign an
nda
i was just talking about that with
somebody about how they're
all these freaks make like i just that's
just like the funniest move ever to
sign like hey baby yeah okay i need you
to sign this
nice i didn't think it was fair at all
with you home with the babies waiting on
him i'm disappointed as i've been a fan
since your first little apartment since
l wasn't even out of your belly yet
i hope you see this i'm not messaging
you for clout
or start drama i couldn't scroll past
your pictures and not say anything
can i just erase the word cloud i know
it's crazy that people really use that
word unironically yeah
and so now catherine the wife is back at
it again on twitter
oh my god laugh my ass off post your
proof that people want to see
how about you post what you got and if
someone tries to sue you i'll pay for it
deal
i swear people believe everything they
read
but this one so i will say in their
defense the girl who messaged her did
not ever send
proof okay so this one's very thin
next one however is much more
damning in my opinion more allegations
came out in october 2019 an instagram
account named
heidi mccl mick colin
released dms between the two also
claiming that austin got her pregnant
the instagram account has since been
deleted
she she wrote in a story i'm tired of
being harassed
i was used and told lies and now you
want to harass threaten and deny my
unborn child
i don't think so i've kept quiet for
weeks but no more i hope you learn
and i hope people know that all the
rumors of how rude you are off camera is
true you're a totally different person
off camera
the most disrespectful man i've ever met
me and my baby will be fine stop trying
to contact me
i am more upset with myself that i fell
for your lies
now here is dms that look are between
him and her
wow so unless they're doctored this is
really compelling stuff and i mean
we can't we can't rule out the
possibility because i think we all know
how easy it is to fake a conversation
but for sure
i'll read it it looks real though
uh he said have you told anyone she said
no
i haven't no one but my sister and i've
told her i'm pregnant nothing more
what the [ __ ] why would you tell someone
unlock unblock my number
don't say [ __ ] to anyone else unblock my
number what the [ __ ] man that baby
probably isn't mine anyway
please can we just talk call me when you
ready to
she said leave me alone he said please
please and then he continues please can
we just talk call me when you
are ready to she said leave oh please
leave me alone she he continues please
just
i'm just scared you would understand but
no
don't need this getting out just want to
handle it quietly i'll pay you whatever
you want please just don't read
it's really small so i'm trying to read
it please just don't
need this getting out the media in the
media please delete
the pictures of us together if you have
them
as proof i'm begging please send me as
proof i'm begging
and please unblock me she's posting
these dm's in her story she says i could
post more
but that would really break your image
now wouldn't it at austin mcbroom
what do you think about that that's wild
so my theory and it is just a theory the
fact because they're always really quick
to be like uh
uh they're this is wrong this isn't real
the fact that they ignored it
makes me think he paid her off or
something yeah and then she erased and
then
probably erasing the account as part of
it yeah they're rich as [ __ ] they could
pay
her a ton of money and my theory on this
is probably the wife knows about all
this yeah
and she's just they they just like this
life and i think
well i think between them i'm sure
there's like lots of arguments but
for them they're like we can't risk our
business and our business is being like
a happy family
you'll find out later actually that they
they should they admit
like they're almost admitting like
happily that oh we didn't talk for six
days haha
you'll see just that that's coming up
right abey
correct yeah okay so but again we're
also we're just assuming here obviously
so
but as with all family vlogs you can
pretty much assume that
the tip of the iceberg is just that you
know you see the pretty
picture and then once the cameras go off
boy
it's a whole different world so i feel
like we have reviewed quite a lot of
evidence on
austin mcbroom being a douchebag
a-i-e-n would you like to defend your
client
uh yeah sure i mean i got a couple
charges here so i'll have to run through
them
uh first mr klein i have a question for
you do you own a jet ski
no i do not when was the last time you
rode a jet ski
probably several years so it's been a
while
so it's probably hard to recall the
feeling of
sitting on a our rxp x
300 wave runner you know
belly full of barbecue brisket
with just the wind at your back feelings
oh so good why barbecue brisket
do you know that can you work too do you
understand that feeling mr klein
sure i could i could put myself there
so if austin mcbroom is sitting in
the middle of los angeles no big body of
water in sight
well and he's got a beautiful beautiful
stunning beautiful sea doo
and no seat to
yeah it's very it's really not that far
from the ocean but you know
ain't something tells me you took a
little too many clout pills today
you know that's not i'm not on trial
here irrelevant
remove it from the record uh the record
remains
anything else to say about uh other than
that that the ocean's not near so you
just invite putting a jet ski in a
swimming pool i mean you're in los
angeles it's not even like you're in
kansas or something
i mean you know that's just one charge
there's multiple things we got to keep
it pushing
was the other thing the headband was
that
oh yeah that's right well first of all i
think you guys
i don't remember the details i don't
remember whether you stole the design
from james charles or whatever i think
you might have
i don't remember i wasn't too familiar
with that i think that's what happened
but
you guys are not impartial this hits a
little too close for home i think the
judge has to recuse himself
okay that's a fair sister snaps yeah
i certainly i certainly can see your
point on that one it's maybe
something that i would rule and bias
so we're here what was the other one was
like cheating
why are you asking me you're the lawyer
dude i'm just
you guys threw a lot of it cheating all
right well
did we see the did we see the plug go in
the socket
no we got a picture of that no
then this is all speculation in it all
right
are you done it's speculation in it
why did you turn english all of a sudden
i rest my case all right all right maybe
ap bring it home come on baby okay i got
home now
i got you all right well first of all
everyone knows that james sister
snatched teddy fresh's design
uh of course i don't think that needs to
be uh discussed
also um saying that he didn't cheat we
were not trying to prove that he did in
fact cheat
we're trying to prove that he's a douche
yeah that being said there's a lot i can
say i feel like the case kind of speaks
for itself but when i was doing my
research i found the cross i
came across a comment from someone named
abu batata
420 abubatata means father of potatoes
in arabic just for the record
and he said awesome mcbroom is like a
human version
of an axe spray bottle and i feel like
that sums him up pretty well that that
comment really resonated with me really
stuck with me and i haven't been able to
get it out since so
i'm going to end my uh prosecution by
saying that
austin is a human axe body body spray
bottle
that's all got them an axe spray bottle
that's pretty funny
okay thank you well let's deliberate
shall we let's let's
let's just let's go farther of potatoes
okay let's review the first count
is the jet ski he's causing a landslide
the dude screams stop they still do it
i mean even do let me ask you something
he's a douche
let me ask you a question hypothetically
is it douchey
to just do it once like let's say that
he didn't
cause a landslide and his neighbors
didn't get mad is it douchey to do it in
that perfect vacuum
it's douchey but forgivable
right it's the fact that he caused a
landslide and did it again
that really puts him in there and
calling them jealous on twitter
right right right right saying telling
him to stay in their lane or something
on to the second point the headband
stealing
um hey although aien does raise a good
point that i probably can't rule
without a dude i also would tell you
that this is my courtroom
and um
[ __ ] you and [ __ ] the procedures right
hey
come on i need that clout i'm taking
that clout pill boy
he's probably gonna be pissed about this
video knowing how defensive he goes
intake i'm gonna use some of that cloud
build
anyway did he rip i don't i wouldn't say
he ripped off the guy's design
clearly his designs are different but he
was heavily he basically stole the guy's
whole business model
and then told him and then like made fun
of him on instagram
instead of being giving him a shout out
which is what he really deserved
you know so dude like for sure douche
yeah no question no
and then the second one was cheating
again no
evidence but you know he was the first
the concrete indisputable thing was he
was in that car with all those girls
which is really douchey to begin with
all the dms and stuff is speculation so
i can't really say one way or the other
on those i'm not i'm can't hold those
those don't hold up in the court of
content
but on all three counts i gotta find the
boy
guilty guilty guilty being a douche
austin mcbroom is a giant douche
here you are don't kill me hear ye
hear you it's a triple kill actually
zach yeah it really wasn't a double kill
triple kill sound bite
triple kill there you go uh yes
austin you are a douchebag this is me
calling you a douchebag
this court finds you guilty now
guys this is only the beginning uh but
we do need to take a brief
recess we'll take a quick break to thank
this court's uh
take a recess to thank our sponsors and
be right back with even juicier
charges
thank you to quip for sponsoring this
court
room quip is the toothbrush we all
mother love and love because it is
accessible
it's affordable and it gives you the
best clean pretty much
in the game i'm obsessed with
toothbrushes
with brushing and from the minute i
first touched equip and laid its
beautiful brussels in my mouth um
i was in love as so as a snob for like
soft brush heads first of all
this is something that they don't tell
you but it has really soft
unique brussels that are it's kind of
like made of like a really soft plastic
kind of vibe so it gives it definitely
cleans your teeth but it doesn't harm
your gums at all and i'm just
i'm so obsessed with the bristles but
besides that
it vibrates you click a button it
vibrates and then it
pulsates every 30 seconds so you know
when to switch the next quadrant of your
mouth
four times left right right
right boom you're done two minute brush
so you get that perfect
brush every time it's an incredible
invention
it gives you the best brush in the game
it's it's it's a tight little pulsating
tube i mean what really more do you need
to know about it i recommend it
big time i love the damn thing and if
you guys haven't tried equip yet
i would definitely get on the quip train
and give it a shot and see if you don't
love it because compared to other
electric toothbrushes
uh it's a steal and it's just as good
so if you go to get quip dot com slash
h3 right now you'll get a first
refill for free that's your first refill
free
if you don't know that means they give
you a replacement brush head and
toothpaste
so you just pop if you know it gets worn
out so you just pop the top off and pop
a new one on
so you get that for free if you go to
get quip dot com
slash h3 spelled g-e-t
q-u-i-p dot com slash
h3 remember guys it's quip better oral
health
made simple
thank you to ridge for sponsoring this
session in the court ridge wallet is the
new
sleek wallet of the future it's
practically indestructible
it's super minimal and it's the solution
to
the huge giant ridiculous wallet that
too many of us carry around i myself am
guilty of that
you know i was carrying around a whole
bag like a crossbody bag
and it's just it's so annoying to carry
the whole thing around so i converted to
the ridge
you could fit eight cards in the slot
and you've got a clip holder and let's
be honest nobody needs to be carrying
around coins in this day and age like
we have we have lost the coin battle
here in america
maybe in europe you have some bomb ass
coins but not in america
i don't carry coins so you show the clip
and the cards you can fit eight cards in
there that slide right out and it's so
minimal i put popped out of my pocket
and i just feel so
aerodynamic and sleek when i had i don't
like [ __ ] all over my body you know what
i mean
we've got all these really cool designs
by the way if you buy this thing once
you buy it for life man this thing is
never gonna break this thing can
apparently withstand nuclear blast they
say here
they found one of these in the wreckage
of uh a test zone out in arizona
with stood a billion megatons of nuclear
force it was totally unscathed
uh fiber you know look at all these
options really cool stuff
yadda yadda you got this they got that
they got some fun prints you know it you
love it you got it forget it
don't take it from me though take it
from
their thirty thousand five star reviews
right it has a lifetime warranty that
means you buy it
once you carry it for life and they
guarantee that this thing will last
a whole life and they're so confident
you're gonna love it
they'll let you take it on a test drive
for 45 days
if you don't love it you can send it
back for a full refund
so what are you waiting for get 10 off
today with
free worldwide shipping and returns by
going to ridge.com
slash h3 that's ridge.com h3
use the code h3 to get 10 off your
purchase
today
welcome back this court is now in
session
moving on to the second charge criminal
snakeishness
snakeishness
it's a cool word snakeishness yeah and
the emojis too
very official so what you see here
it says the ace family basketball
charity event now what does that make
you
think ila when they say it's a charity
event
probably everything from that event went
to charity
right right exactly what everyone would
think
well that's not exactly what happened
introducing the ace family basketball
charity now the j
this charity in june 2018 they held a
basketball charity event and announced
they would donate
a hundred thousand dollars towards a
charity of their choice
and any further money the event made the
event was sold out included a
performance from glenn travis
when the ace family only donated 75 000
and gave no explanation for why it
caused controversy for fans who deduced
they made a higher amount than that
but never went through with their
promise to donate every piece of money
made
however other fans have theorized that
the other money may have gone towards
payments for the event now
before i get any further into this these
are very serious accusations
and i need to put a big caveat in that
these this is only projection
only pr uh well this is only guesswork
right like
i i'm not gonna i can't say for sure
that these guys committed fraud or
or that they stole money that people i
don't even know that it's fraud
necessary i feel like what happened
if what we're saying is true is that
they misled people
and ended up profiting a lot of money
that people thought was going to charity
like you said you say you know
yeah you assume if you're going to a
charity event it's all going to charity
so let me explain
they're selling this false advertising
what would you call it ja raw
or or it's it no it would jarrow which
is not fraud
yeah it's not fraud what is it
i would call that uh false advertising
yeah so
something tells me that uh austin
subscribes to the ja
rules school of business maybe he was
part of the producer
team i wouldn't i love that line charles
such a legend
so um they have this jersey merch it's
65
you see in the top right okay so we're
going to crunch the numbers here okay
they held it at galen center which is uh
where
usc plays it seats ten thousand
five hundred and fifty eight people
that's its full capacity
ten thousand two hundred fifty eight
people the tickets were forty five
dollars
that's four hundred sixty one thousand
dollars in ticket sales
and it does look like it was sold out if
you look at you will watch the videos
right
we have video evidences it was
definitely sold out in their vlogs they
say we sold it out they'd say there was
10 000 people there that they sold it
out wait i want to see video of it oh
it's here let me let me show you the
videos give you some
pro like by the way these guys they're
so big
yeah and there's like all these famous
youtubers
uh ricegum of course was there why
wouldn't he be
and rice comes on his phone he thinks
that's [ __ ] hilarious and epic
that he's on his phone god he's such a
douche
rice cub's stealing the show you're
trying to make a show about austin and
rice comes still in the douche show
[Laughter]
right what did he call ela monotone
monica oh monotone monica right
monotone monica over here
[Laughter]
i'm trying to find the check so they
they did this whole thing about how
they're going to donate a hundred
thousand dollars
and then they cruise out when they check
back for 75
and it's it's made out to ace family
charity of choice it doesn't even say
like they literally they couldn't pick
like the event is already happening
i find that so odd i mean this event is
insane it's sold out
stadium tons of celebrities i was more
that's definitely sold out i mean i
don't see any empty seats i'm just i'm
amazed at how big they are
i've never even really heard of them
until now and then okay like i just
can't believe there's a family channel
selling out stadiums yeah that's crazy
and i mean i don't know as much about it
but i mean considering they filled out
like a whole stadium 75 thousand
i mean not to compare i mean but
your guys uh help campaign if i may simp
um you guys you may way more than that
on your own
i mean you guys didn't have uh a
star-studded basketball game filling out
an arena
i don't know i just find i find that
kind of an interesting number but again
i don't i don't know as much so
it's definitely bizarre so far well
thank you i want to
understand more we're going to crunch
the numbers yeah first of all thank you
for simping a b
we're going to crunch the numbers and
find out how much we're going to guess
how much
money was generated obviously it's a
hell of a lot more
thank you and then they they said they
were going to donate a hundred thousand
and then mysteriously lowered it to 75.
which is odd um okay so but you can see
the event it's pretty epic honestly i'm
very impressed that they're able to put
all this together
but now let's go in the laboratory and
crunch some numbers
the galen center has 10 258 seats
that's max capacity it looked like it
was sold out they sold tickets for forty
five dollars
that means they generated four hundred
one
000 and ticket sales now i'm going to
assume and you can tell me what you
think about this yield that they sold
2 000 jerseys you think that's high
that's a high let's just assume for the
sake of this calculation they sold 2 000
jerseys at 65 a piece
that's 130 130 000
so the total potential taken was
just under 600 000 dollars
that is a little bit of a generous
assumption though
because you don't even know it looks
full maybe it wasn't sold out exactly
and maybe it wasn't two thousand jerseys
but the highest end assumption yeah yeah
but also
i'm sure they had a production company
cost so especially there is a lot of
cost to go with an event like that
insurance the stadium all this the staff
every there's an enormous cost
maybe even 50 percent is caught is just
straight up
cost and also the merch costs money so
yeah i think
50 is pretty fair so if you cut so let's
say we have 600
000 we shave off 50 you have a 300 000
profit yeah right
so like why is it that
you would think that if you're going to
a charity event all of that would be
donated
right yet they not only didn't claim to
donate 300 000
they lowered the initial amount from 100
000
to 75 without explanation that one i
just don't get
like now what was you didn't admit that
just add it yourself
you know that's that's that's the point
they just magically reduce it to 75.
they've clearly also made a shitload of
money and they still
and stinginess wouldn't even donate an
extra 25 000 and
make good on their original promise of a
hundred thousand yeah
so they're making a [ __ ] load of money
from a charity event which doesn't seem
no you're not to make any sense right
that's supposed to be making money yeah
it kind of
defeated what do you call that jaw roll
i would call that uh false advertising
right that's not a crime is it
no but like it doesn't it's not really
charity if like
they're donating a bunch of money and
then you're making a shitload of money
yeah you would need to say like pro
portion of the event it's gonna go to
charity
right you don't just call it a charity
yeah because if they said that people
would be less stoked to go buy sixty
five dollar jersey
right and forty five people because you
know that they're gonna take like 60
of it or something so they did another
charity event
well it was so profitable the following
year they held their second annual
charity event
this time the event got a whole lot
bigger and the charity got a whole lot
smaller
no way really ace family charity event
the next version get hyped and
posted in the last few days is because
we wanted to solidify
this big announcement hey stanley are
you ready we have
officially solidified our next
annual basketball charity vid
and we are doing it one last time here
in los angeles at the staples center
staples center do you know the staples
that's where the lakers play yeah that's
big time [ __ ] dude
i mean the other one was big time [ __ ]
yeah this is like mega big time [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i mean with peace and love i just don't
get what people like about them
like he just seems so he's not really
even likable but i mean
hey i'm just a judge i think i think um
it's just not your your type clearly
it's not my type but i don't know who
the [ __ ] type this is but
god i wouldn't even know him if i saw
him on the street i don't even know what
this type of person
would be very interesting i'd be like
[ __ ] crazy dude
the staple center now
chris brown was here right
that is who breezy is yes oh they're
super easy okay
chris brown who beats up his beats up
his
girlfriends love to have him not just
there he is
as you'll see the uh co-sponsor of the
event oh fantastic
ace family slash chris brown hey isn't
chris brown the guy that beat the [ __ ]
of rihanna
yeah you know good boyfriends do that
right good boyfriends stick with good
boyfriends
it's part of our family values
this is insane man what kind of world
are we living in where this guy
i mean i'm not sure i want to live in a
world where this guy is this famous
right here in l.a i mean i'm not sure
i'm ready for this world
i didn't know that this is the world i
was living you're in city
i'm in the same [ __ ] city
he probably thinks the same thing about
me right
chris brown why is mr beast there
[Applause]
i think he's probably a lot smart he's
probably just happy to be involved
i can't hate on mr b he's a sweetheart
the legend james
james look at his album holy [ __ ]
oh yeah james charles sings the fingers
the national anthem
i love it that's all i get come on
i wanted to see james charles sing the
national anthem
it's just a super cut and i was blowing
through it all can you look can you
in the meantime get me a link i want to
watch this it's honestly not that funny
it's it's a pretty good rendition of the
oh wow
really well there's two other singers
they're probably you're hearing them
more than him they turned his mic off
you think
my original cut i included more of it
and then i was like this isn't really
funny because it's just it's just the
national anthem
you think they turned dan says they
turned james charles mic off well i
don't know if they turned his mic off
but
i've heard him sing in other videos and
it wasn't as good as this you heard it
here
dan says they turned his mic
does that make sister sense oh is that
chris brown the dude who beats the [ __ ]
out of uh his girlfriends
nice let's have him involved
jake paul good dude all because of the
ace family i'll make this happen
me and chris brown we giving away a
hundred thousand
to a charity that we believe in because
this would not be possible
without all of you we would not be able
to write this check here for a hundred
thousand
do you see all the hubbub they're making
over 100 they rate they must have raised
millions of dollars in this event
also just quick aside but a moment ago
when he said me and chris brown were
donating a hundred thousand that kind of
sounds like they're both donating a
hundred thousand
no joint together which means they're
doing
50 000 this time they're generating way
more money
and they're donating less money
and they're making a shitload money and
by the way all this [ __ ] hubbub
for just a hundred thousand i mean a
hundred thousand dollars a lot of money
i'm not saying it's not
but they're generating probably millions
of dollars from this event
yeah so like forgive me of
charity to profit is off way the [ __ ]
off
to call but they call it a charity event
which is super misleading
that's how you get all these people
involved don't aren't these people
feeling all like
tools like like right look at that clout
boy
cop pill oh
wow baby i need that clown
we really did it you did it
one week later new house baby at their
new oh oh for real
yeah that's not a joke oh this is their
that's funny their new house
were you saying it as a joke yeah i
didn't know that no this was the next
video
the next video posted after whoa what
was that ja
rule that's not fraud no
right no that's just false
i advertising call that uh false
advertising that's not fraud
oh you're a little early aren't you
super early
it's okay come on in hey this is a week
later guys
what's going on everybody
i know a lot of you guys have been
wondering where have we been where's the
ace family
thank you to everyone who came to the
event thank you to everyone who watched
the event
for everyone who supported us for this
event we cannot thank you guys enough
and none of this
would be possible without you guys the
ace family so with that being said we
kind of need a little break
wait who's the ace family are we they's
family are you there's family
we're all their fan base is the ace
family but i do find it strange
because they're always thanking the ace
family saying
right it's very like egocentric
everything about it
hey i just want to say this wouldn't be
possible
without the client
the reason i i i i chopped that up just
to keep it moving but
um i do want to just emphasize at no
point do they mention
the money the charity aspect of the
event
they just say thanks for coming and then
they just move on
so once again the event have like a
website or
no so once again it was marketed as a
charity event
let's crunch the numbers break this down
at the staples center stalled out
21 000 seats the tickets
right this time last time was 45 this
time it ranged from 48
to 250 wow
average ticket price we'll assume is 70.
ticket revenue 1.5 million
okay so they're selling the 65 dollar
uh uh jersey
and i think if we do 20 again which
would that would be like 4 000. you
didn't include that one this time did
you
i guess not but yeah it would be about 4
000. uh so what's 4 000 times 4 uh 65
it is uh
260 thousand dollars so they're they're
at about
one they're about 1.75 in revenue right
now
now renting the staples center paying
staff getting insurance all
that's [ __ ] expensive dude yeah we're
estimating half a million it could
be higher than that yeah easily half a
million yeah
the thing is if they sold it to staples
center as a charity event they might
have been able to get it cheaper which
would have been why it was all framed as
a charity event as well
just a thought i don't know that but
it's really hard to guess
the numbers yeah it's a lot i'm sure
it's super depends on what time of year
too there's a lot of factors for them
but let's just say 500 that seems
reasonable
i think it was probably more i think it
was probably more like 750 000
just to give them the benefit of the
doubt that still leaves a million
dollars left over
then you consider the fact that they
donated a hundred thousand dollars 50
of it was from chris brown so they
donated fifty thousand dollars
of a million dollar take
which is you know five percent
that's less than sales tax
they advertise it as a charity event
there's no evidence that anything more
than that was donated to charity
really it's a straight to our mortgage
event
yeah it's a down payment event yeah it's
a down payment event
so i mean this whole story kind of blew
my mind
is that you could throw a so-called a
self-titled charity event
in which you keep 95
of the money they made a million dollars
they donated 50 000 they kept 95
of the money into their pockets
yeah very cool i mean
it's just it's insane i mean it just
is [ __ ] nuts if
we ever did anything like this before it
would be literally
my head would be on a pike outside
youtube headquarters
i don't know why they get away with all
this stuff this is like ja ro what is
this
i would call that uh false advertising
you know i
i i'm surprised that this isn't
being investigated by authorities
because i do get fraud vibes from this
to be totally honest because i don't
think you
because it's super misleading and i
don't know that you can just [ __ ]
call something a charity event and then
keep 95 of it
but i think you need to be sued by
somebody so
i don't know we're here right well i'm
not
yeah i'm suing them [ __ ] it i didn't
even attend
[Laughter]
i just love that the next video is them
in their 10 million dollar house
that was so funny which by the way
it was two houses that they purchased
for 10 million dollars they then
combined them into one giant mega house
so
really the house is probably 15 or so i
i remember reading a headline that it
was like a 20 million dollar house
the property i i was able to find out
that they bought the property for 10
million
and that there were two houses on the
property and then they
can they'd like voltron the houses
together yeah i think they're
trying to say they have like a whole
hill and woodland hills
that they just cause mudslides on all
the peasants below
do you think the mudslides affect the
valve galley what a b
so do you think the mudslides affect the
value of the home yeah
the neighbors not theirs right
all right i've seen enough ai ian i dare
you to defend this
uh well mr klein uh i mean
as far as i'm concerned this is a little
thing i've
heard referred to as donation shaming
something i believe you've been heavily
criticized for in the past
well i don't think we're donation
shaming him i think
we're merely acknowledging i i
i admit that the amount he donated is a
large amount it's just
it's more the misleading aspect of the
event that i take across with
oh interesting you know i think it's
it's also interesting to hear uh talk
about
fake donations coming from you mr klein
why is that i mean based on some twitter
accounts i
i follow they've been alluding to
certain things
that might be a bit dubious regarding
some
money you might or might not have given
away
recently i don't what just tell me what
you're talking about because i don't
know
well i mean i've been told that you scam
you lie
and you steal money you scam and cheat
and steal and lie and
cheat have you been watching keemstar
yeah name more than dramaalert name one
additional news channel other than
dramaalert
you know that's not relevant i'm just
saying i think you should recuse
yourself
recuse yourself why you want me to
recuse myself because keemstar lied
about me and said that i committed fraud
close the trial um you know this is just
kangaroo why are you even criticizing me
you're supposed to be defending
the the ace family not i'm not on trial
you know i i've been told that out of
that hundred thousand dollar giveaway
five hundred dollars might have
disappeared you rocketed that
what are you going to buy a ps5 you
thought you were going to get slick huh
you know what's funny that is equivalent
to the amount of money they donated
from their basketball event
yeah it is 500 is the equivalent amount
of how much they donated right
no fifty thousand it would be fifty
thousand it would be five thousand would
be the equivalent
of the hundred thousand yeah [ __ ] i'm an
idiot
[Music]
how dumb am i
compelling stuff do you have anything to
say in defense of them are you just
going to attack me
i i just attacked you that was really
myself
a b well uh yeah that sounds like a
typical dramaalert fan
whenever ethan asks him to provide a
source he he couldn't he said it's not
relevant
so yeah i believe that you have been
watching dramaalert um because
he's charged with his chart
yeah and um i don't know like i said
again the evidence speaks for itself the
dude has frosted tips and a chin strap
in 2020. the guy's the guy's a snake
you can't trust a guy who was rocking a
look from the 90s
in today's world i don't trust him he's
a snake
that's it frosted tips is pretty
incriminating i have to agree with you
on that one
i hadn't considered that thank you baby
anytime
all right hit the music yeah he's a
[ __ ] douche
[ __ ] him guilty
we don't need to linger on too long i
mean come give me a break
what the [ __ ] is this you can't pocket a
million dollars
from a charity event and donate 50 000.
yeah
correct me if i'm wrong ace family but
you're not
you haven't corrected anybody who said
this which leads me to believe
that you made a lot of money and i guess
everyone who participated in that is
kind of an idiot
too i need that clout because like if i
part if i participated in a so-called
charity event and then
i don't think you should blame those
people because
that's the problem of what ace family is
doing these things a lot of time
work on just the basis of trust you just
you just have to trust them that they're
doing the right thing
i mean for someone like i don't know all
these big influencers that were there
they're busy with their own life there
it's not their
job to go and make sure this is a legit
event well
at least in my opinion to an extent i
agree
but i have to assume that everybody was
like yo go to this event
it's a charity event i'm going to be
there that's why they were able to fill
out all these seats because all these
huge influencers
were promoting it but then when you hear
that they've only donated fifty thousand
dollars
and you know they sold out the staples
center
i would probably be asking him for an
explanation
well that's why you're not his friend
and especially the second
you wouldn't be asking questions but i
don't think you guys would hang out
again it doesn't like people ask
questions
i don't hang with people that frost
their tips anyway so good point ab
but it happened a second time that's
what's crazy and the second time was
even bigger he's like i'm gonna run this
i'm gonna do this crazy anyway he's a
guilty [ __ ] i mean
you know ricegum i expect this of rice
gum but chris brown
really
hey isn't chris brown the guy that beat
the living crap out of rihanna
i vaguely remember that all right and
now on to our final charge misdemeanor
destructive delusions wow that's a
mouthful
they're there in the jet in their house
yadda yadda let's get to the juice
haze family exposes themselves by
accidentally uploading a clip
showing austin yelling at his wife
catherine
this happened actually very recently
remember this
uh this happened just like this month
right or last month yeah last month
in a clip the family posted youtube
austin seen briefly shouting at
catherine
and swearing as they try to film a
segment
many fans think that the clip was left
in the upload video as a mistake
and it has left fans concerned about the
dynamic between the couple one person
wrote
she looks like she's about to cry
another person said they thought that it
was evidence of an unhealthy
relationship here's the clip that was
left
in their vlog by mistake which is
awesome welcome back to our channel guys
what's going on everybody
look at my hair no good thing i don't
have to know i'm gonna say good thing
i'll be on camera today
okay good okay my hair looks [ __ ] up
i'm gonna
film like this so just go okay bro
really i mean like
he's all butter about how his hair looks
like is that just
the whole premise is kind of interesting
right like how my new
they think about these things okay one
two
three hey
welcome
oh look at my hair good thing i'm not
gonna be on camera today
he really thinks his hair is so [ __ ]
up everyone's like dude look at his hair
look at his hair anyway they left it in
thoughts on the clip itself what does
that speak to
um i feel like
being in the kind of world of being in a
relationship and recording
i feel like those situations kind of
happen it wasn't that bad actually
like i can see us having a moment like
that and it doesn't necessarily mean
much
more like i agree thank you my personal
opinion on that
but there's more evidence so let's just
take that as one piece
because i feel like their response to
that where they try to acknowledge it
makes it worse
interestingly because i had the same
reaction you did but when i saw this i
was like oh that sounds worse than what
i thought it was
so first she tweeted out i hope you guys
enjoyed today's vid super chill video
something different and yes aus and i
get frustrated with each other sometimes
it's called marriage
i wish people would stop expecting
people to have a perfect life oh but
that's what you portray
life is just not real that's not
realistic love you baby
and tag them low i mean that's your
problem people think you're having a
perfect life that's what you're putting
out there
oh and then they acknowledge it in a
clip called we went to therapy
here's what they say about it i recently
uploaded a video a day in the life of
catherine
and there was a clip in there that was
not supposed to be uploaded
it was not supposed to be in there i
accidentally left it in there i
edited the video and you guys know
they're on purpose you guys oh my god
do you believe that that's the video elo
no
there's no chance they have a family
they have all the like i mean oh
the [ __ ] there's no way she edits the
video this kind of video that's weird
i was editing the video you guys know
that austin has been editing the videos
since day one
and basically we just want to talk about
that for a second so pretty much
um it was a rough morning that morning
there's zero percent chances
so what is she saying she's saying
normally he edits but this time she did
this was her first time ever editing a
video which is not something that you
just jump into by the way that's
very weird there's no way they edit
their videos at this point in their
career with all they're doing
no way sorry i don't believe it what the
[ __ ]
well they got in uh they got their
previous beef because they were paying
only a hundred dollars maybe they
couldn't find any other editors in l.a
stiff people like that it's crazy come
on guys
um it was a rough morning that morning
and we were
frustrated with each other we were
arguing and obviously they only saw
a clip of that yeah you guys only saw
the a small clip of it you guys didn't
actually see me yelling before thank god
and i was like a tendency to like
always defend over like she's oh i was
yelling at him
it was me that was yelling at him also
it's the first time i'm editing so i
[ __ ] up
and he was in and he was in a car with a
bunch of girls at coachella and
our marriage is perfect you weird like
you should just look
very defensive of him you know it's
always
i don't know it's odd i could be off
base here too but
the way that he's like staring her down
the entire time as she explains it do
you find it like the body language
the body language is kind of i mean yeah
we're obvious that's reading really deep
into it but i know what you mean he's
like
really poor he's like really imposing
his body
over her before
and at that point i was so frustrated
and i didn't like how it was going
because it was my video that i wanted to
do
and at the end we had the babies yeah
and at the end he was like my hair is
[ __ ] up like
i would not be filming like this and i
was like okay and at that point it was
like the fourth try and i was so over it
and that was the one that we used and it
just so happened to make it in the video
and that's like
just dead the truth um but i will say
that they said you were crying they said
you were crying before that were you
crying no i wasn't crying
i said you got a bruise on your forehead
stopping that's what they say
stop it you're lying
no you covered up with your makeup today
yo did you hear their neighbors
screaming at them that's like a real
sound bite stop you could just hear them
in the house all the time
oh listen people are crazy no listen no
we always
argue okay something that you guys don't
know listen
is that recently pretty recently i want
to say like just a couple months ago
there was a period where austin and i
didn't talk for four days we didn't talk
for four days we were so irritated with
each other
and we didn't show that on camera we
didn't film that we didn't talk about it
it's our business
that's normal no i know so not talking
for four days
seems like i i don't think in our
whole time together we've ever like that
that seems like a
really serious thing not talking for
four days like that's ice cold
dude yeah you know like am i wrong is
does that seem normal in a healthy
relationship to not talk for four whole
days
that's that's the weirdest thing i've
ever heard in my life i mean i can get a
date like oh we didn't talk for the
whole day
if you have a big fight or something but
four days i
i personally don't ever see something
like that happening the only time
it's like the only time i saw something
that extreme happen is like
my mom and my dad after like 50 years of
marriage when they were really upset at
each other
so it's pretty extreme they've gone that
long without talking to each other
they did two weeks of not talking really
oh [ __ ]
they're the world champs of not talking
oh wow so i guess yeah two weeks that is
pretty
that it must be a guinness world record
well you know i thought it was like they
were just frustrated in that moment but
when i saw this i was like oh wow it was
more serious
i'm i'm trying to partner so i'm trying
to understand still the situation so was
it that
like she was doing a video about her so
that's what she was editing
is that yeah apparently she was doing
like a day in her life
so he was like hey oh i'm glad i'm not
in this video my hair's [ __ ] up
yeah got it yeah okay because i didn't
really understand
but i get lady macbeth vibes from her
you know what i mean
i feel like she's she's as in on this as
he is
you know what i mean yeah because look
at this
look what look at all they've got all
right here we go
normal couple normal no i know but i'm
just
not arguing no i'm just saying i'm just
letting you guys know that like
four days of not talking it's pretty
wild for us that's
normal especially when you're business
partners not only parents right your
business
not talking for four days [ __ ] you know
i've seen it
many of times in my own did they do
daily videos
and stuff like people argue how often do
they post
it's more like post pretty frequently i
mean it's not daily but they've got
dates
a few times a week yeah vlog [ __ ]
mother of [ __ ] i clicked the video that
time right on the [ __ ] video dan
it's weird for me too so we uploaded a
video
yeah god i'm just wondering if it's
weird that like were they making videos
even though they weren't talking to each
other
yeah that's what i wonder too but it
sounds like maybe they didn't make a
video in that time frame
[Music]
and he was like my hair is [ __ ] up
like i would not be filming like
so is there anything more to see is that
i don't think so okay
okay so you know obviously
me and you can attest that it can be
stressful
not only marriage but working together
so honestly i
i'll i i can overlook that entire
situation i could totally
yeah let that off you know but now now
we go on to the penis-shaped lollipop
situation ela
in january of 2019 austin posted
snapshot videos of him buying
catherine's little sister a penis-shaped
lollipop
show catherine what you have in your
hand he said in a video of her little
sister licking the explicit candy
soon after the clip went viral and the
duo was called out for sexualizing the
young kid
though the pair never commented on the
scandal they did take a break from
social media from one month man these
guys have been through it all
so this should this should i have to say
uh what was really something
uh you know what'd you say
what'd you say what are you trying to
get to
you love what oh god
you don't need that come on
you know it's spencer spencer's has like
some toys and stuff too it's a mix it's
weird yeah
it's like pop culture
what did he say he said talk to me baby
that's so messed up vin diesel this
this is dude we got to put a line on
this in diesel
that's that is just bro you can't do
that
please bro put that in a bag right now
keep that in the bag forever do not show
that to anybody okay
that's [ __ ] up dude
she's so [ __ ] beautiful
you can't do that i'm laughing because
it's so insane that you're hitting those
sound bites
but you can't do that all right
guys i'm in so much trouble but she said
she's going to steal it if i didn't buy
it so
it's better me buy it
[Music]
this is a vlog diet whatever yeah
exactly i promise you something don't
show nobody that lollipop okay
okay thank you let's go
come on let's go
put that away put that lollipop away
[Music]
guys i'm not gonna lie kathryn's sister
is a seven what are you
oh my god i gotta go i'm leaving
so here's what my theory on this whole
thing is that he's
basically directing exactly what he does
from the beginning yeah he goes oh grab
that like she doesn't know what she's
doing she's a sweet innocent girl
he goes grab that lollipop and yeah now
take it out
and now and i'll take it out and walk
around the mall with it exactly what i
was thinking so yeah
so like this disgusting yeah just
disgusting dude
to go off of that too in spencer's i
mean like they have a mix of stuff like
t-shirts and stuff but then they have
like one corner that's just like
a shitload of like dildos and oh so
yeah he definitely directed her to do
this
i feel like any of us that makes videos
can immediately like
see how it was going yeah in their head
yeah
he's got vlog flogaidus he's been taking
the clout pill too much and
he's just he's not existing what
yeah on the cloud bill you know
it's really it is really sick and
there's just one part he goes it's our
little secret
like that's i don't like hearing
grown-ups say that to
two kids especially when it comes to
stuff like this it's our little secret
bro i don't want you having any little
secrets with this girl
yeah you know what i mean stop
and he even he probably even told her to
lick it at this point outside and
like you know because she she doesn't
know what the [ __ ] she's doing she
doesn't want that she doesn't care about
that lollipop
she probably saw like you know she
probably saw a tootsie roll by the
cashier and would rather have that
also she's seeing him laughing so it's
just exactly it's a game yeah
yeah yeah also you're right most of the
counters in these stores are a bunch of
candy they have like dragon ball z a
bunch of kid stuff
but then there's the dildo section that
has the peanut shaped lollipops in the
back she definitely wanted the dragon
ball z
[ __ ] lollipop down at her eye level
you know what i mean
exactly she's not strolling through the
dildo section being like i want
that one [ __ ] weirdo
i need that clout yeah too much dude
that's your little secret that's your
little secret bro you cannot
say that bro no let's try michael
jackson
[ __ ] sorry ab
that's what michael jackson says this is
our little secret
we'll discuss this later a b is a uh
a b is a simp of many people including
michael jackson which we have a problem
about we i have conflict with a b over
the symptom for michael jackson
anyway that was disgusting i'm afraid to
respond
disgusting behavior
but you know can we just write it off to
vlog-itis it happened early last year
moving on to the next part and this part
this shirt this clip's been shared all
over the internet and it's really tough
to watch because
first of all i'm a dad so i understand
the affection that a man has for his
children i understand it
very well i love my son and
you know i get it like like uh but
the problem is doing stuff on camera and
putting it on youtube
i haven't watched it yet but i'm just
saying in this clip so this this
happened recently too and it's being
shared like big time by a lot of people
in this clip that's made his rounds on
the internet austin's seen slapping his
four-year-old daughter's butt
and he says in a suggestive way oh my
god i can't oh god damn
i can't even people call also on social
media i understand that but the way he
looked at her and say
god damn was kind of creepy one
concerned viewer tweeted before another
added the way the little girl pushed his
hand away from her butt too i didn't
notice that
let's watch yeah come on
i'll be working out too much you're
getting fat why don't you get fat yeah
lights
god i can't all i got to say
so like if he just slapped her butt i
probably i mean i could easily write
that off his fatherly affection
but the way he says ah god damn i can't
did kind of creep me out
i'll be working out too much but you
know what like
i think you're right it's just god i
can't i feel like if there
if this wasn't being made as a video and
they were just in their house
like what maybe you know maybe it's just
being silly or whatever and
yeah i i can't necessarily be honest
that's that's probably what's going on
here i don't think he's actually
doing anything in private that's like uh
you know like this doesn't indicate that
he's
doing anything in private tour i
wouldn't say no yeah
yeah and i'm the first to immediately go
to that direction
yeah when i see it i give no benefit of
the doubt
normally so but i feel like this is like
my problem with doing this is just
as a parent i wouldn't do that on camera
and then put it on youtube
because there's creeps out there
watching youtube
and i wouldn't participate that's the
price you pay when every [ __ ] thing
you do with your family goes on the
internet
yeah and that's why there's just so much
inherently
there's so many landmines with the whole
family dynamic vlog
channel you know but that's that's part
of the deal if you're gonna go in that
direction you have to be super
responsible
no this guy in there
so i i do think
i do think it's kind of creepy i agree
with that but i don't think it indicates
that
he's doing he's anything worse is going
on
that's my personal opinion on that
and then finally this one is hilarious
they made a video remember the context
is out of touch they made a video called
we work at a restaurant for 24 hours
austin and catherine did a video where
they challenged themselves to see what
it would be like to work in a restaurant
and catherine snaptroy snapchat story
she explains how they are literally
working right now at a restaurant
austin has been making food for the past
hour and i have been taking orders do
you understand how cool that is
here's a clip guys
we are literally working right now at a
restaurant
yes we are awesome has been making food
for the past hour and i've been
taking orders do you understand how cool
that is
family people are like yeah it's really
cool when you have to [ __ ] do it
seven days a week
making minimum wage to barely pay your
rent how cool
you know it this is like some real marie
antoinette [ __ ] like
oh yeah look at me it's so much fun to
work at chipotle for an afternoon
this hat is so cute it's so cute i love
wrapping the burritos and
it's so fun okay i'm returning to my
woodland hills fortress what's also
funny is it wasn't like they were even
working hard for that time well
especially austin i put a little
snapchatting
yeah yeah if that was real the boss you
can't have your phone
yeah the [ __ ] you do get your ass back
to work
but the title says for 24 hours what's
to do with that
i don't know it sounds like they were
working for an hour it looks yeah and
the super cut i made right here if you
guys
don't know if you guys want to check it
out it was like an hour it looked like
here's the super cut that would be a
cool idea if we would work
at a restaurant for the day i personally
never worked in the food industry so
this will be really interesting and then
he
never got the opportunity to work a nine
to five because after college
we started creating videos and so this
is going to be a first time experience
for me i'm super excited
this is so [ __ ] out of it there's
nothing exciting
yeah there's nothing great there's
nothing romantic
yeah i mean you just really wanted to
say that you never had a real job
i think they're trying to is like be
relatable
right after college we got super big
with our videos and so
this is gonna be so cute because i'm
gonna try to be one of you
for one hour and see what it's like this
is like
but please notice my orange lamborghini
in the back right
i'm gonna go work one hour in chipotle
anyway i'll drive there in my orange
lamborghini
actually working like cooking taking
orders
uniforms yeah so when we get there we're
gonna change our cars i already got some
boots today
wait that's
[Music]
so they drive a lamborghini and a
rolls-royce
yeah you know they're just causing
trouble goofing around with their camera
and stuff
i get to make one of these today
this is gonna be so disruptive her
trying to use this it takes a minute to
learn how to use this [ __ ]
yeah like it takes a few good weeks to
learn how to effectively use that
machine
i know i've actually [ __ ] worked in a
restaurant and it sucks everybody there
hates it
[Music]
can you please order me a smoothie i'm
thirsty um
and then there's a little break moving
just check it up on you breaking i'm
just checking on it
came back here to grab some booty and
get a kiss
all right people watch this i mean i'm
sorry i just
i can't understand anyone that watches i
can't
i can't do it i have to i i i consider
myself an
empathic person generally but uh i i
can't do it
can't if i'm gonna see that on the job
both of you
that makes more sense it's a guilty
pleasure i mean is this this is too i
don't know
maybe yeah i'm just making sure you
can't even get some love
yeah that guy hates your guts bro
you want to make sure it's good
you know when you work and you cook a
lot
uh you tend to get hungry especially
when you're seeing what you're making
the whole video is just i'm trying to
steal
food i can get a smoothie yeah how much
i'm just scooping off
this trigger
[Music]
i remember working a really long shift
and actually starving the whole time
but guess what you actually can't eat
you actually start yeah when i when when
i was there they would make
i guess it was nice that they even
cooked for us but they would make like
employee food
on the side that was like [ __ ]
that you could during the shift no on
your lunch break they would make food
for you but you say they said that you
didn't eat
like the food in the kitchen yeah
i survived off of fries for like five
years yeah a restaurant
yeah yeah i survived off bread for
for yeah one of the places we only could
eat the bread
it was good bread so we went [ __ ]
hard on the bread
yeah now he knows what it's like
he's been there for an hour he's having
a good time
can i get a smoothie please boss gives
you a smoothie
it's your favorite drink yes thank you
boss okay give it to the catcher
[Music]
what is he what are you doing what what
are you doing
you need to go back to work and you're
leaving trash
oh my god so good so good oh wow
a little unexpected treat he wasn't even
trying
it's just it's so demeaning to people
that actually have to work for a living
you know what i mean oh so people
actually got mad at them
catherine that was so much fun that we
literally had so much fun
it's not fun when you do it every day
for seven plus hours
doing what normal people do so you're
not normal people you've ascended to the
level of some kind of god imagine being
so cut off from reality
imagine working at a restaurant for fun
while others work minimum wages to even
survive
yeah and at least if they actually tried
to take it seriously you know and
really perform as one of the crew they
didn't even try to no they're just
disrupting the entire operation
drew goodin came slam dunked on him
he said imagine being so disconnected
from reality that you got this excited
about pretending to work in a restaurant
for two hours
405 000 likes by the way wow
yeah and then another comment imagine
being so privileged that working in a
restaurant is a challenge
yeah pretty embarrassing stuff all right
ai
in go ahead defend this your robot ass
you have no empathy
well i mean i think they're doing a
great service personally
it's kind of two birds one stone sort of
thing they get to
walk a mile in the lowly proletariat
shoes
right and understand how the other side
lives which you know
is that a bad thing i thought that was a
good thing no it's a good thing
and i'm all for anybody you know
trying to uh
reinforce and push the idea
into people's heads that work is
necessary
the long slow driving wheel of capital
is needed for all
uh can you restate that last point
well no i we well it's under the cold
hard
thumb of the capital machine is my
favorite form of living
and this is really enforcing that idea
keep them working keep them pushing
maybe i'll give you a smoothie maybe
maybe i can't
ask me nicely i'll give you a smoothie
maybe
just a drop
so i can't tell you you're not grow
capitalism or if you're being ironic no
he's pro
he's very pro you just like that it
causes suffering human suffering
and and and and
you know i got something to say yeah
that penis lollipop looked kind of good
ordering this before i thought you don't
even have food
you want dick that didn't look kind of
juicy
[Music]
get the [ __ ] out stay focused here ain
okay what are your thoughts ain on um
the machine that they're using to
organize the orders you notice that she
was working
do you believe that that machine is
being treated fairly
do you believe that as working rights
you know i think she could have been a
little more
careful with the machine a little more
loving tender
and whispers few sweet nothings in its
ear
but it doesn't really bother me because
that machine is going to replace all of
them
fairly soon and and be running the
establishment
right all righty thank you ai in his uh
message is is uh steady as always
death to all humans am i right be
thankful to the capitalist gods
all righty serve that dollar baby
are you saying that the capitalist gods
are the driving force behind your
creation i'm just wondering why you're
so pro-capitalism
look we want to get into this we want to
get into this
right now i am curious maybe not no
my batteries are dying my mouth is
barely moving
you've been here so long all right let's
cut it off
stop all right ab uh how do you tackle
that
well as someone who's been a waiter for
you know over six years
in the past um yeah i could see why
people are
flustered i feel and it makes sense that
they've never waited before i feel like
i feel like waiting is one of the best
and worst jobs in the world because it's
the worst for the obvious but it also
treats
it it teaches you how to treat people um
and i feel like you know
people don't have a job or experience
like that they grow up and you know they
do crazy [ __ ] like
snapping at their wife or not getting a
good angle of their frosted tips
uh putting on fake charity events you
miss out on a lot of human experience by
not engaging in you know nine to five
jobs and you lose touch
and that's what happened clearly with
this family and uh
i rest my case interesting
thank you very much all right let's
deliberate
so um the fact that
they were successful early on is
obviously not
a bad thing about them i mean good for
them
good for them my problem is that
they um
they didn't even try like if you're
gonna make a whole video
about going and getting the experience
of one of these jobs that you never had
go and really try it like they just
they just treated that restaurant as
like a a set
for them to have fun with and goof
around
if they were really trying to like uh
make an appeal to
normal people they would at least come
out being like oh that was
tough like wow i was going to do it do a
whole shift
yeah you know yeah do a whole
[ __ ] shift
but that's not entertaining is it i mean
if we go back
to the beginning maybe it would be
interesting you're right
if we go back to the beginning we start
with austin
this is a man who causes mud slides and
does it again
this is a man who goes to coachella
while his wife is at home pregnant with
kids and he's partying with a bunch of
uh thoughts i believe i would tell you
don't come back technical term
you would i would i would not let you go
to coachella while i'm pregnant
i wouldn't i mean i wouldn't ask to do
that right i know
honey it's just so important to me
um this is a man who's
put on two charity events in which he
pocketed
i can at least say of the second one 95
of the proceeds or the profits that's
insane
this is a man who
buys penis lollipops for his niece
vlog itis but i also need to say
that the woman is showing some signs as
well she's always coming to
you know coming to the defense is a good
thing like i feel like
she's complicit in all this you know
she they've got a good thing and they
don't want to jeopardize it and so maybe
he's [ __ ] up and she's like i know
but i don't want to jeopardize i can't
jeopardize this gravy train
right which fair enough
and it is very gravy
yeah um it's
i guess it's uh their personal decision
how authentic they want to be with their
fans
you know but the truth is i think of
everything i saw
the staples center thing yeah was the by
far the craziest thing
and i feel like they should be forced to
answer for that to reckon for that
and they have never been held
accountable for that they've never
explained
the logistics the breakdown of how that
happened
and again i feel like they should be
held account for that but
apparently they don't nobody cares they
just moved on
you know i'm assuming i guess everyone
just assumes they just pocketed the
money
so that yeah i mean unless they say show
otherwise
just assuming they pocketed that yeah
950 thousand dollars
out of the million
i will say you know that's not fraud ja
rule is very clear about that
not accusing them of fraud but you know
ultimately i gotta say
my my feelings on this is that like with
all family vlogs you know
there's always a dark side because you
cannot
mix family and children and
it's not just work it's the constant
need to be on camera
the constant need to put your children
on camera constantly to show every
aspect of your life on camera
and to like every day you don't feel
like it but kids you got to do this
thing for the cat you know
it's like you cannot do that healthfully
it's impossible
i think it's impossible and a lot of
money
add that to the mix right and a lot on
the line
a lot of money so you know and i feel
like it's
i feel like the fans just need to just
need to be aware of all this and
you know i really don't know what else
to say but
but yeah um i i sentence him to 10 years
in jail for fraud
oh i don't have actual legal authority
okay not fraud i'm not accusing him of a
fraud i sentence him to
be having another scandal for being
doing something dumb and having to deal
with that
damn i need that clout that's harsh that
is hard trust me
that [ __ ] i hate it when another [ __ ]
comes up you're like oh
[ __ ] so i sentenced him to that
and that's it on the ace family
so um anything else bailiff
there dead air i'm i'm like yo i'm
asking you questions you could throw
dead air on me
no stop
the jet ski thing was pretty good too
yeah we got some great sound bites
out of that well guys thanks for
watching i hope you learned something
new and again take all this with a grain
of salt because i really don't know them
at the end of the day this is all yeah
just project this is all guesswork based
on the evidence at hand
um that being said thank you to our
prosecution a b
thank you to ai ian who um
is a big fan of the ace family as i
understand it right love their content
slit yeah it's litty thank you to dan
thank you to zach
aka vin diesel who made some really
inappropriate comments
that was totally not okay and that i
condemn in the strongest possible words
and uh thank you all to you guys to to
that klein family
because without the klein family we
wouldn't have any of this right
all right guys this court is adjourned
[Music]
you